Welcome to the presentation
on dividing decimals.
Let's get started
with a problem.
If I were to say how many times
does 0.28 go into 23.828?
So you're going to see that
these dividing decimal problems
are actually just like the
level 4 division problems.
You just have to figure out
where to put the decimal.
So what you do is you always
want to take this decimal and
move it over as many spaces
as necessary to turn this
number into a whole number.
So in this case, we have to
move it one space, two spaces
over to put the decimal here.
Well, if I did that with
this number I have to do it
with this number as well.
So I moved it over two spaces
to the right, so I have
to move this decimal two
spaces to the right-- 1, 2.
Decimal goes here, and I
put the decimal right
above, right there.
Now I can treat this
28 as a whole number.
And if I want to, let me see if
I could-- well, I want to erase
the old decimal because if you
were doing it with a pen you
would kind of have the
same problem I have.
So now we do it just like a
level 4 division problem.
So we say, how many times
does 28 go into 2?
Well, no times.
2 is smaller than 28.
How many times does
28 go into 23?
Once again, still, it goes
into it zero times because
23 is smaller than 28.
How Many.
Times does 28 go into 238?
So let's think about that.
28 is almost 30.
238 is almost 240.
So 30 goes into 240 eight
times Because 3 goes
into 24 eight times.
So I'm going to guess that 28
goes into 238 eight times.
And it literally it a guess.
You have to try out some
numbers sometimes.
8 times 8 is 64.
8 times 2 is 16.
Plus 2 is 22.
Subtract.
I get 14.
I guessed right because the
remainder when I divide 28 into
238 and I say it goes into
it eight times is 14,
which is less than 28.
So 8 was the largest number of
times that the 28 could go into
238 without being larger.
So now I bring down this 2.
Once again, you recognize this
is just purely a level 2
division problem-- a level
4 division problem.
So now I say, how many
times does 28 go into 142?
Well, once again, I'm
going to approximate.
28, it's almost 30.
Let's see, 30 times 4 is 120.
So yeah, I'll take a guess
and I'll say let's say it
goes into it four times.
I could be wrong, but let's
see if it works out.
Let me get rid of this old 6.
4 times 8 is 32.
And 4 times 2 is 8.
Plus 3 is 11.
2 minus 2 is 0.
4 minus 1 is 3.
Huh.
Interesting.
So it turns out that my
remainder here is larger than
28, so I actually could have
divided 28 into 142
one more time.
So let me go back
and change that.
See, it's not a
mechanical thing.
And if you feel unsure
sometimes, you just have to try
numbers and see if they work.
And otherwise, you raise or
lower the number accordingly.
So let me erase that 4.
I'm going to try
not to mess up.
Erase all this stuff down here.
I probably should have tried it
out on the side first before
doing all this and I wouldn't
have had to go back
and erase it.
And then let me get back
to what I was doing.
So when I went into it four
times the remainder was too
large, so let me try five now.
5 times 8 is 40.
5 times 2 is 10.
Plus 4 is 14.
142 minus 140 is 2.
Good.
2 is less than 28.
This 5 is correct.
Now I just bring down the 8.
28 goes into 28
exactly one time.
1 times 28 is 28.
Remainder of 0.
Done.
So 28 goes into
2,382.8 85.1 times.
Or you could say, 0.28 goes
into 23.828 85.1 times.
That's the answer
we had gotten.
And that makes sense.
It's always good to do a
reality check because if I took
85.1 and I multiplied it by
0.28, it makes sense that
I'd get a number around 23.
0.28 is almost 1/3.
So 23 is almost 1/3 of 85.
So at least it makes
sense in rough numbers.
When you're doing decimals, if
I had gotten 800 here instead
of 85, I'd be like, oh,
well, 0.28 times 800?
I don't know if that equals 23.
So it's always good to just do
a reality check and get a sense
for at least the magnitude of
what your answer should be.
Let's do another problem.
Let's do 3.3 goes into 43.23.
That's a 3.
So first thing we want to
do is move the decimal.
We just have to move it one
space here, so we move it
once space here as well.
Put the decimal right up here.
And now it's just a level
4 division problem.
33 goes into 4 zero times.
33 goes into 43 one time.
That's easy.
1 times 33 is 33.
Do the subtraction.
43 minus 33 is 10.
Bring down this 2.
33 goes into 102?
You could eyeball that one
and say, about three times
because 3 times 33 is 99.
3 times 33 is 99.
102 minus 99?
Well, that's easy.
That's 3.
We just bring down this 3.
33 goes into 33 one time.
1 times 33 is 33.
0.
So 3.3 goes into
43.23 13.1 times.
Or, if you move the decimal
over, and when you move the
decimal over to the right one
spot, all you're doing is
you're multiplying both the
divisor and the dividend by 10.
Which is fine as long as you
multiply both of them by 10.
It's also like saying 33
goes into 432.3 13.1 times.
Let's do one more problem.
I think I have time.
YouTube puts a limit
on this stuff.
so let's say 2.5 goes into
0.3350 how many times?
Well once again, let's move the
decimal point over one here.
So we move the decimal
point over one here.
Put the decimal here.
So how many times
does 25 go into 3?
Well 0.
So you could put a 0 here
just for fun if you want.
How many times does
25 go into 33?
Well, it goes into it one time.
1 times 25 is 25.
33 minus 25 is 8.
Bring down the five.
25 goes into 85?
Well, we know 25 times 3 is 75.
So it'll go into
it three times.
3 times 25.
We know that's 75.
85 minus 75 is 10.
Bring down the 0.
Up here we had brought
down the 5 before.
And 25 goes into
100 four times.
So our answer is 2.5 goes
into 0.3350 0.134 times.
So as you see, the only
difference step between what
we're doing when we're dividing
decimals and when we're doing
level 4 division is we just
have to make sure we get the
decimal in the right place.
You shift the decimal here
enough so that this becomes a
whole number and you just have
to shift the decimal here
the same number of times.
And once you do that it
just becomes a level
4 division problem.
And the whole trick with level
4 division is always be willing
to try numbers, and if
the numbers don't work,
adjust them accordingly.
Don't feel that there should be
a way that you can just always
power through these problems.
You have to do a little bit of
trial and error and maybe use
your eraser or do some work
on side every now and then.
But anyway, I think you're
ready to do some dividing
decimals problems.
I hope you have some fun.